in his meeting with the Palestinian
president the U.S Secretary of State
sticks with the line that Washington
remains committed to a Palestinian State
alongside Israel but Anthony blinken
knows it's a diminishing Prospect we
have been
clear and consistent neither side
should take any unilar actions that
right now potentially would would add
fuel to a fire and over the medium to
long term would make the prospects of
achieving two states even more distant
than um than they currently are
so far 35 Palestinians have been killed
this year in confrontations with Israeli
Security Forces
Benjamin Netanyahu returned to power in
December and appointed far-right
politicians and religious nationalists
in senior cabinet posts one of them
national security minister itma bengvir
has promised to give more gun permits to
Israeli citizens and expand illegal
settlements in the occupied West Bank
I think there's a very high risk of
escalation the this new Israeli
government is very fascist it's far
right it's very intent and committing
and inflicting violence upon
Palestinians and in fact you know their
their political mandates were premised
on that so I think in the weeks and the
months to come we're going to see a
crueler regime of occupation inflicted
upon the Palestinian people Mahmoud
Abbas and the Palestinian Authority are
reliant on International pressure to
make sure Israel honors its commitments
when it comes to the occupation of East
Jerusalem and the West Bank
we want a complete cessation of all
unilateral Israeli actions that
undermine all signed agreements it is
the main way back to re-engage
politically and end the occupation like
the heads of the Jordanian and Egyptian
intelligence agency sat down with a bass
ahead of his meeting with blinken an
indication of the concern in the region
about the security situation here it's
understood they asked the Palestinian
president to adopt a flexible position
with the Americans
Palestinian Authority wasn't expecting
much from Anthony blinken's visit
certainly not a commitment to re-engage
on a peace process with Israel the US is
concentrated on the war in Ukraine
threats from Iran and its relationship
with China there's certainly no evidence
of any real pressure to stop a slide
into a wider conflict here the
Palestinians are on their own
Bernard Smith Al Jazeera Ramallah